If I am in full remission now, I think I am.
Can you test me for what I should do about my autoimmune condition now?
Yeah, so many of you started with us knowing that you have a comorbidity,
might be an autoimmune disease, might be heart issues, might be blood pressure issues,
might be cholesterol issues, and we kind of put those a little bit on the back burner
because we are trying to deal with a very serious disease in cancer.
So now if the cancer isn't fairly stable state, and now we have to start looking at the other comorbidity.
So the answer is yes, so we can test you for those things.
What would you do differently with cancer versus an autoimmune disease?
Okay, so if I had cancer and an autoimmune disease, which if you don't already know,
you probably do have an autoimmune disease.
Most people have an autoimmune disease and they don't have a diagnosed.
So if you're over 30, you probably have at least the start of an autoimmune disease.
So what would you do whenever I said you treat a lot of diseases differently if you had cancer,
if you've no early head cancer, for instance, I have heart disease that I have high blood pressure
and I'm taking nitric oxide, and now I got diagnosed with cancer.
Well, I would say you got to change to something else for your blood pressure
besides nitric oxide, because nitric oxide is a very strong stimulator of venejaf
vascular endothelial growth factor, and that is what cancers love fast.
So we don't want to be stimulating the vascular growth into a solid tumor.
Yeah, blood cancer wouldn't be worried about that like a leukemia.
But even a lymphoma where you have a solid tumor or any other cancer with solid tumor cancers,
you wouldn't want to be stimulating vascular endothelial growth factor.
So I would lay off the nitric oxide while we're dealing with the cancer.
And then you could possibly go back on that if you're in full revision and you're doing so much better
and you need to now be more concentrated and get your blood pressure down
and nitric oxide was working in the past.
Well, you have an autoimmune disease.
What do you want to stay away from if you have an autoimmune disease?
You want to stay away from specific immune stimulators like different herbals and vitamin C.
Even at a high dose.
So at a high dose, vitamin C is an oxidizing agent, but it's still an immune stimulant.
So can an autoimmune patient take IV vitamin C?
Well, if you're trying to kill cancer, I guess the cancer trumps the autoimmune disease.
So yes, you can.
But now if you have to know that it can flare your autoimmune disease and it can be
you're going to use immune stimulants, you can flare your autoimmune disease.
And anytime you stimulate your immune system for any other reason,
you're going to kill that what you have antibodies against first and definition of an autoimmune disease,
is you have antibodies against self tissue.
So yeah, you're trying to kill the cancer.
At the same time, you're stimulating your immune system to kill the cancer.
But you're stimulating your immune system and it's killing self antibody.
So it's killing your own tissue, right?
Well, you deal with that while you're trying to kill the cancer.
Now the cancer is in remission.
Now I might back off on my immune stimulants per se.
Now that's one of the what's one of the huge things I love about mushrooms, okay?
So mushrooms, polysaccharides, they're immune stimulators.
Well, not really, they're immune modulators.
So mushrooms, the polysaccharides in mushrooms are really immune modulators.
So they won't directly just stimulate a broad based immune system,
which could then make my autoimmune system autoimmune disease worse.
They will stimulate my immune system to kill the cancer,
but not necessarily to kill other tissue.
So mushrooms are immune modulators.
Most people with autoimmune conditions don't have flares when they take mushrooms.
And then a beautiful thing about mushrooms.
Like polysaccharides in general, mushrooms that evolve immune, the aloevia immune product.
They're safe on those usually with an autoimmune disease.
Long answer to that question. Sorry.